[Music]
have you ever wondered if there's a
mysterious missing episode from your
favorite cartoon TV series there just
may be and we have compiled ten secret
lost cartoon episodes you never saw make
sure to watch this video and tell the
end to find out which the loud house
episode you'll never see if you like
hearing about cartoon TV scandals as
much as we do make sure to subscribe to
the things and give this video a big
thumbs up today we are showing you ten
secret lost cartoon episodes
you never saw Pokemon electric soldier
porygon from TV show and trading cards
to a Pokemon go revolution the Pokemon
phenomenon has managed to remain
relevant transcending generations since
its first episode the series popularity
is not without fault however especially
when it comes to an episode that North
American audiences will never see have
you ever worried that your favorite
cartoon could put you in the hospital
most would agree that it's a pretty
unlikely situation but pokemons electric
soldier porygon never aired for an
American audience for precisely that
reason it was just too dangerous the
episode features a trip into cyberspace
as Ash and his friends travel into a
pokeball transmitter machine in a
defensive move at some point in the
episode pikachu produces a thunderbolt
attack that was portrayed by bright
strobe lights viewers in japan enjoy
this effect until they started suffering
from serious side effects an
approximation of up to 700 people mostly
children reported a range of physical
reactions to this episode from headaches
and nausea to fainting spells and
seizures the effect was so strong and
widespread that it became known as
pokemons shock the episode caused a drop
in Nintendo shares as the well being of
viewers became a serious concern for
both Japanese and American broadcast
networks the fact that pokemons
international popularity was not
affected as a result of this disastrous
episode is a treatment to the loyal fan
base and audience it continues to
cultivate Spongebob Squarepants the
sponge who could fly spongebob is that
happy-go-lucky sponge that lives in a
pineapple under the sea and we just
can't get enough of this character
wonky sense of humor usually working at
the krusty krab or going on adventures
with patrick the starfish
spongebob keeps audiences coming back
for more the show always begins with a
sing-along opening led by patchy the
pirate
and is narrated by the quirky french
narrator however there is one episode
that is known as the lost episode called
the sponge who could fly
the premise of the episode is that
spongebob decides to figure out a way to
achieve flight with the help of Patrick
of course finally achieving his goal by
inflating his pants spongebob becomes
occupied with helping out his Bikini
Bottom neighbors instead of flying with
jellyfish the end of the episode
showcases a rare performance by patchy
the pirate who loses the remote in the
episode forever making it the series
lost episode the lesson then becomes
that SpongeBob's adventures will never
truly be lost as the memory of his
shenanigans will live on in the mind of
the show's loyal fans the show has been
running since 1999 and remains to be one
of the most popular animated series
whether we can rewatch episodes or not
the characters and memorable approach to
mundane problems promises to continue to
remain in viewers memories the Powerpuff
Girls see me feel me know me the next
lost episode is an example of American
censorship as it was never aired on
American television Powerpuff Girls is a
longtime favorite among viewers and
often challenged notions about girls
inability to fight these three sisters
work together combining their strengths
to take down evil villains who try to
take over the world see me fill me
Noemie was an episode that American
audiences did not see for its
controversial political undertone in
this episode The Powerpuff Girls are
tired of the pressure that is entailed
in being superheroes the girls therefore
decide to make a deal with mine battle a
gnome who promises to take away their
superpowers in return for eliminating
all the evil in the world not only did
the episode take a darker turn than
usual but it was set up to be a
psychedelic rock opera deemed
inappropriate for its young audience
rather than being relieved of their
powers and living as normal young girls
the Powerpuff Girls watch as helpless by
standards as more and more people
start to address mine battle as a leader
and succumb to a very cult-like Society
although the ultimate lessons about the
necessity of the balance between good
and bad this episode's communist
politics made it a lost episode to
American audiences Teen Titans trouble
in Tokyo this next series used the term
last episode to its advantage and
released a feature-length episode called
trouble in Tokyo or the last episode
Teen Titans is a character-driven series
about a band of adolescent superheroes
on top of the issues related to being a
superhero they also have to contend with
all that goes along with being a teen
that's a lot to handle the series is
based off a comic book series and the
last episode definitely pays homage to
its origin not only is the
feature-length episode seeped in
Japanese culture but the series was
influenced by anime so situating this
last episode in Tokyo was a natural fit
not only is the location important to
the special edition episode but it also
features Robin and sapphires first
romantic onscreen kiss known for their
banter and growing relationship both the
TV show and comic display the
progression of the relationship and it
really culminates in the lost episode
trouble in Tokyo instead of referring to
the lost episode as a shameful secret
Teen Titans used it as a way to take the
beloved storyline in a unique direction
Dexter's Laboratory rude removal some of
the lost episodes can be quite obscure
while others have reached an impressive
level of infamy Dexter's Laboratory was
originally aired from 1996 to 2003 as a
children's show it featured a young
scientist who house to secret science
lab in a hidden area of his family home
this prodigy had many ingenious ideas
that would consistently recomme him at
the source of the show's conflict was
DeeDee
Dexter's sister who would relentlessly
involve herself in Dexter's plans and
experiments eager to find a way to get
him into trouble there was one episode
however that no one had seen and that
was only released 10 years after the
show had ended on Cartoon Network Adult
Swim the premise of the last episode
called brood removal is that Dexter had
decided to create a way to remove the
Rudess from DeeDee
per usual the intended outcome was not
achieved and instead both DeeDee and
Dexter became the rude version of
themselves for the duration of the
episode although any swear words were
bleeped the Cartoon Network refused to
air the episode because it was
considered inappropriate for its young
audience it might have taken a long
anticipated decade before fans got to
see the lost episode
but it also helped the show sustain an
adult following for a show originally
meant for kids The Simpsons dead barked
The Simpsons is famously known for being
the longest-running animated series on
television running since 1989 this
fictional family is loved for the
satirical episodes that reflects our
society though the show has often had to
deal with censorship from the network
straddling the line between provocative
and offensive it has only one reported
missing episode the episode known as
dead Bart is definitely among the most
mysterious on our list with no actual
confirmation that it has ever existed
this urban legend does have some ground
to it and continues to be one of the
most speculated episodes on the Internet
dead Bart was allegedly created when
writer Matt Groening was under pressure
by the network to respect strict
deadlines during the first season of the
show
Groening has never confirmed that the
episode was ever written but managed to
evade any answer at all the episode true
to its name was about the death of Bart
Simpson and is reportedly extremely
disturbing it seems that despite lack of
proof that this lost episode ever
existed in the first place
audiences enjoy speculating about the
strange nature of this Simpsons anomaly
do you think this episode exists or is
it an elaborate internet rumor let us
know your thoughts in the comments below
and wait until you hear about the loud
house lost episode Fairly OddParents
sweet revenge Fairly OddParents is an
enduring series about a boy Timmy and
his fairy godparents Wanda and Cosmo who
look after him and help him get through
his daily life using the power of magic
although most of the episodes end with
heartwarming lessons the 21st episode of
the fifth season does anything but warm
your hearts the episode 1 extra to the
usual 20 episodes per season has a dark
and horrific twist
unlike
any of the other episodes in this series
not much has been reported about the
lost episode and few people have watched
it the episode opens like all other
episodes Timmy in his bedroom being
greeted by the fairy couple he spends
every day with however the episode
quickly takes a gruesome turn when
Timmy's biological father attempts to
throw a weapon at his own son missing
him and impaling Kosmos I instead the
episode ends on an even darker note with
a code that translates to you're next
this lost episode brings up a lot of
unanswered questions but it seems like
audiences didn't miss much by not seeing
this creepy rendition of Fairly
OddParents
will stick to the upbeat tone prominent
in the rest of the 20 episode seasons
Futurama the tale of two Santa's
Futurama is definitely not a
conventional cartoon set in the future
this sci-fi keeps fans on their toes
with its sarcastic humor this lost
episode has resurfaced but it was not
permitted to air on its original release
date in 2000 because it was too early a
timeslot for what the episode had in
store if you haven't heard about it yet
we're talking about the tale of two
Santa's episode which ended up being
much more of an anti Christmas special
than anything else the episode featured
a new character that is now loved by
many adults who got to watch this lost
episode a year later during its new 9
p.m. timeslot the murderous Kris Kringle
is a robot Santa Claus instead of
offering cheer and joy typically
associated with a holiday special Kris
Kringle required you to barricade your
chimneys and hope to live to see another
day instead of falling victim to the
stalking Claus robot this episode made
it to the TV screen but it remains
listed as a lost episode as it was
deemed inappropriate to an original
younger audience unexpected but still
humorous futuristic twists like this one
is exactly why the show is loved by so
many fans Arthur room to ride author has
been a well-loved TV series for decades
with an after-school special Phil this
show continues to teach children by
modeling positive relationships and
solutions to common everyday problems
these lovable animals became characters
that everyone could identify with as we
follow them through their
adventures even guests would sometimes
appear in their animal form for an
episode one of these celebrities was the
reason for PBS pulling an episode that
is now known as Arthur's lost episode
room to ride was an episode to inspire
the residents of Elwood to become more
involved in biking and installed bike
paths throughout the fictional town
unfortunately PBS couldn't have
predicted that their bunny disguised
guest star Lance Armstrong would come
forward confessing to his use of
enhancement drugs in competitions his
popularity for raising awareness for
cancer through LIVESTRONG bracelets is
just one reason why Armstrong became
such an idol to children and adults
alike however once admitting to taking
steroids
Armstrong contradicted the episodes
central theme and was therefore deemed
inappropriate to air since then
Armstrong has gone as far as returning
his Olympic bronze medal and has
received praise for the way in which he
has taken responsibility for his actions
all at all Armstrong has adopted an
Arthur like model the episode remains
lost and will never be seen the loud
house enough is enough the loud house
features a boy Lincoln and the daily
struggles he faces while living with 10
siblings this show has been popular on
Nickelodeon and YTV alike the show's
lost episode enough is enough
has recently been discovered as a
tentative finale to the third season but
has not nor will it make it to the
screen this episode remains to be lost
but not without some details as to the
gory storyline
Lincoln usually remains true to his
siblings not ever engaging in behavior
that might put their lives at risk this
lost episode however is a completely
different side of Lincoln revealing a
much more aggressive side of the
character in enough is enough
Lincoln lacks patience when dealing with
his sisters and resorts to disturbing
tactics like slamming his sister's head
into a wall
although surviving in a very large
family surely comes with some
understandable challenges this much more
disturbing take on violent sibling
conflict was quickly buried and never
made its way to the TV screen which the
loud house character would you think is
most likely to lose their cool let us
know in the comments below
that's it 410 secret lost cartoon
episodes you never saw if you want to
see more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 cartoon secrets finally
revealed thanks for watching
[Music]